taste bu they come the mic I never once
ever had a moment in my life where I
like the AOS where I thought it tasted
good I never talked to anyos grow up
with the shoes grow up yeah you're 45
years old you're running around like
Punky Brewster it's enough shout out
Punky it's enough grow up you just told
tens of thousands of people that you
cried over a goddamn wook you just said
to me irony grow up with the shoes when
you were wiping away the tear that was
still there from crying over know
emotion had an age limit put that dark
meat down and the the the juiciness and
the grease and and the stuffing and the
gravy by the way you're not getting
gravy without dark meat it looks like it
looks like dolphin meat gravy's coming
from the fat baby
hard now we're talking a great Point
taste